.
>> THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO INSIDE POLITICS.
WE BEGIN THIS HOUR WITH DRAMATIC
BREAKING NEWS.
THE PERIL OF TRUMP.
AMERICA'S TOP GENERAL TWO DAYS
AFTER THE JANUARY 6TH CAPITOL
INSURRECTION SO WORRIED ABOUT
THE THEN PRESIDENT'S ANGRY AND
ERRATIC BEHAVIOR, HE CALLED A
SECRET MEETING WITH TOP DEPUTIES
INCLUDING THE CHAIN OF COMMAND
FOR THE COUNTRY'S NUCLEAR
ARSENAL.
GENERAL MARK MILLEY'S MESSAGE AT
THAT MEETING? NO ONE WAS SO ACT
ON ANY ORDERS FOR MILITARY
STRIKES, EVEN FROM THE PRESIDENT
UNLESS MILLEY, THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE JOINT CHIEFS WAS PERSONALLY
INVOLVED IN THE SIGNOFF AS
CALLED FOR BY PENTAGON
PROTOCOLS.
DETAILS OF THE TOP SECRET
PENTAGON MEETING AMONG MANY OF
THE STARTLING REVELATIONS ABOUT
THE FINAL DAYS OF TRUMP IN
"PERIL", A BOOK.
OUR CNN SPECIAL CORRESPONDENT
OBTAINED AN EARLY COPY OF THE
BOOK.
>> JOHN, WOODWARD AND COSTA, AS
YOU SAY, REPORT THAT GENERAL
MARK MILLEY TOOK TOP SECRET
ACTION TO LIMIT PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S ABILITY TO MAKE A
MILITARY STRIKE OR TO USE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
LET ME JUST SET THE STAGE FROM
THE BOOK.
ACCORDING TO WOODWARD AND COSTA,
MILLEY IS DEEPLY SHAKEN FROM THE
ASSAULT ON THE CAPITOL ON THE
6th.
WE BELIEVES TRUMP, TO YOUR
POINT, IS UNSTABLE,
UNPREDICTABLE, AND WOODWARD AND
COSTA WRITE, MILLEY BELIEVES
THAT TRUMP IS IN SERIOUS MENTAL
DECLINE.
HE ALSO HAS BEEN TALKING BACK
CHANNEL TO THE CHINESE.
HE IS AWARE FROM INTELLIGENCE
THAT THE CHINESE ARE ON EDGE,
BECAUSE OF JANUARY 6TH.
AND BECAUSE OF TRUMP'S BEHAVIOR.
SO HE'S TRYING TO REASSURE THEM
BEHIND THE SCENES, AND MILLEY
TELLS HIS SENIOR STAFF, QUOTE,
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT A
PRESIDENT'S TRIGGER POINT IS.
AGAINST THIS BACKDROP, SAME DAY,
JANUARY 8TH, MILLEY GETS A CALL
FROM SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE, NANLY
PELOSI.
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THIS CALL, BUT
WOOD ARD AND COSTA GOT A
TRANSCRIPT OF THE CALL.
PELOSI HAS THE SAME CONCERNS
THAT MILLEY DOES.
THE PHONE CALL IS DRAMATIC.
IT IS BLUNT.
AND PELOSI WANTS MILLEY TO
REASSURE HERE THAT THE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS ARE SAFE.
AND THIS IS THE EXCHANGE.
PELOSI, WHO KNOWS WHAT HE MIGHT
DO?
HE'S CRAZY.
YOU KNOW HE'S CRAZY.
HE'S BEEN CRAZY FAR LONG TIME,
SO DON'T SAY YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
HIS STATE OF MIND IS.
HE'S CRAZY, AND WHAT HE DID IS
FURTHER EVIDENCE OF HIS
CRAZINESS.
GENERAL MILLEY SAYS, MADAME
SPEAKER, I AGREE WITH YOU ON
EVERYTHING.
MILLEY REASSURES PELOSI ON THE
CALL, BUT WHEN HE GETS OFF, HE
THINKS TO HIMSELF, SHE'S RIGHT.
AND HE DECIDES TO TAKE THIS
EXTRAORDINARY ACTION.
>> SO HE HAS THIS CALL WITH THE
SPEAKER IN WHICH SHE IS AGITATED
AND ESSENTIALLY REINFORCES HIS
CONCERNS.
HE'S SEEING THIS INTELLIGENCE
AND ACTUALLY HAVING A BACK
CHANNEL.
THAT'S EXTRAORDINARY.
BACK CHANNEL WITH HIS
COUNTERPART IN CHINA SAYING CALM
DOWN.
EVERYTHING WILL BE OKAY.
AND HE DECIDES TO CALL THIS
EXTRAORDINARY MEETING.
TAKE US INSIDE.
>> RIGHT.
AND BY THE WAY, ACCORDING TO
WOODWARD AND COSTA, MILLEY NEVER
TELLS THE PRESIDENT ABOUT THESE
BACK CHANNEL CALLS.
SO HE CALLS AN EXTRAORDINARY
MEETING OF THE NATIONAL MILITARY
COMMAND CENTER, THE PENTAGON WAR
ROOM.
HE BRINGS THE GENERALS IN, AND
THE OFFICIALS, ACCORDING TO
WOODWARD AND COSTA.
JUST REMEMBER HE IS NOT
TECHNICALLY IN THE CHAIN OF
COMMAND.
HE IS AN ADVISER TO THE
PRESIDENT.
AND HE TELLS THE GENERALS AND
THE OFFICIALS WHO RUN THE WAR
ROOM, NO MATTER WHO CALLS YOU,
YOU GOT TO LET ME KNOW.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAYS.
QUOTE, IF YOU GET CALLS, NO
MATTER WHO THEY'RE FROM, THERE'S
A PROCESS HERE, A PROCEDURE.
NO MATTER WHAT YOU'RE TOLD, YOU
DO THE PROCEDURE, YOU DO THE
PROCESS, AND I'M PART OF THE
PROCESS.
LOOK, MILLEY MAY BE CRITICIZED
BY SOME FOR OVERSTEPPING HIS
AUTHORITY, BUT ACCORDING TO
WOODWARD AND COSTA, HE FELT THAT
HE COULDN'T TRUST TRUMP, AND
THAT WE WERE IN SUCH A DANGEROUS
TIME OF RISK THAT HE HAD TO TAKE
ALL NECESSARY PRECAUTIONS.
HE ACTUALLY HAD AN EXPRESSION
FOR IT.
HE CALLED IT THE ABSOLUTE
DARKEST MOMENT OF THEORETICAL
POSSIBILITY.
WHAT TRUMP MIGHT DO.
>> AND SO GENERAL MILLEY KNOWS
AT THIS POINT HIS RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE PRESIDENT OVER THAT
DEMONSTRATION ACROSS THE WHITE
HOUSE WAS TOXIC.
IT WAS -- SO PERHAPS HE'S
WORRIED ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIP.
HE ALSO HAS OTHER EVIDENCE.
THEY WRITE IN THE BOOK ABOUT A
SECRET MEMO.
THAT GENERAL MILLEY FOUND OUT
THE PRESIDENT WAS TRYING TO
QUICKLY PULL OUT TROOPS OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN BEFORE HE LEFT
OFFICE.
>> MILLEY HAD PROOF THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP COULD GO ROGUE.
HE'D DONE IT ONCE BEFORE.
A WEEK AFTER TRUMP LOSES THE
ELECTION, ON NOVEMBER 11th, THIS
MEMO, A MILITARY DIRECTIVE,
SHOWS UP UNEXPECTEDLY AT THE
PENTAGON.
IT IS A SECRETLY DRAFTED AND
SIGNED BY THE PRESIDENT MEMO,
SAYING YOU'RE TO GET OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN BY JANUARY 15TH,
BEFORE TRUMP'S PRESIDENCY IS
OVER.
THERE'S JUST ONE PROBLEM.
NO ONE ON THE NATIONAL SECURITY
TEAM, NO ONE AT THE PENTAGON
KNEW THAT THIS HAD BEEN DRAFTED
AND SIGNED.
IT HAD BEEN DONE BY TWO TRUMP
LOYALISTS AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
THEY HAD DONE AN END RUN AROUND
THE NATIONAL SECURITY TEAM.
THEY WERE COMPLETELY BLIND
SIDED.
SO MILLEY DECIDES HE'S GOING TO
GO OVER A NO NOTICE SURPRISE
VISIT TO THE WHITE HOUSE, AND HE
CONFRONTS NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER ROBERT O'BRIEN WHO SAYS,
I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THIS
EITHER.
AND MILLEY SAYS TO HIM, QUOTE,
WHAT DO YOU MEAN YOU HAVE NO
IDEA?
YOU'RE THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER TO THE PRESIDENT.
AND THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THIS, AND THE
CHIEF OF STAFF TO THE SECRETARY
OF DEFENSE DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT
THIS.
THE CHAIRMAN DIDN'T KNOW.
HOW THE HELL DOES THIS HAPPEN?
IN THE END O'BRIEN CONVINCES
TRUMP TO NULLIFY THE MEMO AS WE
ALL KNOW HE DIDN'T PULL OUT THE
TROOPS.
BUT IT SHOWS TWO THINGS.
IT SHOWS THAT TRUMP WAS WILLING
TO DO AN END RUN ON HIS NATIONAL
SECURITY AND MILITARY ADVISERS.
IT ALSO SHOWS FOR ALL THE
CRITICISM NOW THAT TRUMP AND
SOME OF HIS ALLIES ARE MAKING
ABOUT BIDEN'S WITHDRAWAL FROM
AFGHANISTAN, HE HAD JUST SIGNED
AN ORDER TO GET OUT VERY, VERY
QUICKLY.
>> OKAY.
EVEN MORE QUICKLY.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND THERE'S OTHER NEW
DETAILS.
WE KNOW ABOUT THE DYSFUNCTION IN
THE WHITE HOUSE AT THAT TIME.
ESPECIALLY THE TENSION BETWEEN
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS THEN VICE
PRESIDENT, MIKE PENCE.
DONALD TRUMP WANTED MIKE PENCE
TO JUMP IN FRONT OF THE TRAIN.
AND WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THIS
BEFORE.
THEY HAVE NEW DETAILS ABOUT THE
JANUARY 5TH th MEETING.
THEY HAVE TO ACCEPT THE RESULTS
OF THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE, TO
ACCEPT JOE BIDEN WILL BE THE
NEXT PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
THEY TAKE US INSIDE THAT
MEETING.
>> THESE ARE DIRECT QUOTES OF
TRUMP AND PENCE.
IT'S THE EVENING OF JANUARY 5TH,
AND THEY CAN HEAR THE MAGA
SUPPORTERS OUTSIDE ON
PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE CHEERING
BLOW HORNS, AND DONALD TRUMP IS
TWISTING MIKE PENCE'S ARM, AND
HE GESTURES TOWARD THE
SUPPORTERS OUTSIDE, THAT THEY
COULD HEAR, AND HE SAYS TO
PENCE, IF THESE PEOPLE SAID YOU
HAD THE POWER, WOULDN'T YOU WANT
TO?
IN OTHER WORDS, OVERTURN THE
ELECTION?
PENCE SAYS, I WOULDN'T WANT ONE
PERSON TO HAVE THAT AUTHORITY.
THEN TRUMP SAYS TO PENCE, BUT
WOULDN'T IT BE ALMOST COOL TO
HAVE THAT POWER?
>> PENCE, NO, I'VE DONE
EVERYTHING I COULD, AND THEN
SOME TO FIND A WAY AROUND THIS.
IT'S SIMPLY NOT POSSIBLE.
TRUMP, LOSES IT.
NO, NO, NO.
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND, MIKE.
YOU CAN DO THIS.
I DON'T WANT TO BE YOUR FRIEND
ANYMORE IF YOU DON'T DO THIS.
>> IN ADDITION TO THE
DYSFUNCTION THERE, THERE ARE
ALSO MORE DETAILED ACCOUNTS.
AGAIN, WE KNOW THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WAS TRYING TO FIND
HELP ANYWHERE HE COULD AND IT
WAS HAVING A DRAMATIC IMPACT
ACROSS THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, NOT
JUST ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
BUT DIFFERENT REACTIONS TO THE
PRESIDENT FROM LEADERS WITHIN
HIS OWN PARTY.
>> 100%.
SO MITCH McCONNELL IS PLAYING
ALONG FOR A WHILE, BUT THEN
WOODWARD AND COSTA REPORT IN THE
BOOK THAT PRIVATELY HE WANTED TO
BE DONE WITH TRUMP AND CALLS HIM
A KENTUCKY SLOGAN, AN OTTB.
OFF THE TRACK THOROUGHBRED.
OBVIOUSLY WE KNOW KEVIN McCARTHY
WAS GOING DOWN AND CONTINUES TO
GO DOWN TO MAR-A-LAGO.
THE JANUARY 6TH SELECT COMMITTEE
IS GOING TO TAKE A VERY CLOSE
LOOK AT THIS BOOK.
STEVE BANNON IN IT.
THE LAST BOOK WAS CALLED "RAGE".
THIS COULD BE CALLED RAGE 2.0".
THERE'S SCENE AFTER SCENE OF
TRUMP LASHING OUT, SHOWDOWNS,
TOP ADVISERS DESCRIBE SOME OF
THESE SCENES AS SOMETHING OUT OF
FULL METAL JACKET OR "DR.
STRANGE LOVE".
I WANT TO ALSO SAY THE BOOK ALSO
DEALS WITH JOE BIDEN'S FIRST SIX
MONTHS IN OFFICE, WHY HE PULLED
OUT OF AFGHANISTAN.
AND WANTED TO DO THAT.
AND ALSO THE SHADOW OF TRUMP
OVER THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE.
AIDES USED TO WARN EACH OTHER,
DON'T USE THE T-WORD.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN WANT TO SAY HIS
NAME.
>> WE'RE GOING TO TALK MORE
ABOUT THIS IN A FEW MOMENTS AND
BRING POLITICAL REPORTERS IN TO
HELP WITH THE CONVERSATION.
I WANT TO PULL THE PIECES
TOGETHER.
YOU TALKED ABOUT COULD BE RAGE
2.0.
I SAY PERIL IS APPROPRIATE.
THE OFF THE TRACK THOROUGHBRED
WANTS TO GET BACK ON THE TRACK.
WHEN WE LEARN THIS HISTORY,
IMPORTANT FOR EVERYBODY OUT IN
AMERICA, DEMOCRAT, REPUBLICAN,
INDEPENDENT, OR SOMETHING ELSE
TO LOOK THROUGH THE HISTORY OF
THIS, THE CONDUCT, THE STEPS
TAKEN BY GENERAL MILLEY, THE
RAGE AND FURY OF THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
BUT THE PERIL IS THE BEHAVIOR IS
CONSISTENT.
AND HE WANTS TO SHAPE HIS PARTY
TODAY, TOMORROW, INTO 2022, AND
HE'S ALREADY TALKING ABOUT A
COMEBACK IN 2024.
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION AS YOU
READ THROUGH THIS BOOK THAT HE
IS PREPARING FOR 202